alors l'oeuvre que je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui s'intitule le
corps de viviez racault qu'il a réalisé
en 2006 alors c'est une composition
numérique de grand format 90 sur 67
points 5 cm et à plusieurs
prisons ont été montées pour restituer
un ensemble homogène et cohérent alors
la photographie représente le corps d'un
jeune femme flottant sur les eaux
sombres
tenant son corps qui semble sans vie le
regard tourné vers le ciel
l'attention de l'artiste est tournée
surtout vers le détail des formes et les
des contrastes le vif vert de la visite
végétation par exemple s'oppose aux
sombres aplats noirs qui est servi comme
forme fond de l'image ensuite le malheur
du visage et la couleur blanche de la
robe de mariée s'oppose à l'obscurité
profonde de l'oeuvre au delà de la
figuration le jeu subtil des clairs
obscurs
la mise en scène des paysages et des
personnages ou le recours à l'allégorie
introduisent dans son oeuvre une énigme
et une ambiguïté propres à l'univers
fantastique vivien qui transforme un
univers fantastique et poétique
en univers inquiétante voire même
presque fantasmagorique cette
photographie rappelle l'oeuvre de john
everett millais qui s'intitule ophelia
en 1850 2 dans cette peinture à l'huile
en découvre le corps sans vie d'ophélie
flottant sur les eaux sans merci